le congrès des maires de france qui a
donc pris fin hier clôturée par un
discours d' emmanuel macron discours de
plus d'une heure alors qu'a dit le chef
de l'état comment ont réagi les maires
ou à ça avec sa bien des chefs il se
peut qu'il y ait eu des malentendus au
début
une dose d'humour des mots d'hommage de
remerciement hier emmanuel macron s'est
lancé dans une opération séduction face
au maire avec qui tout elle est si mal
commencé vous avez pour toutes celles et
ceux qui m'ont croisé à travers le grand
débat et beaucoup d'autres j'espère pu
découvrir que j'aime et malgré tout
beaucoup de ski et votre action il ne
fait d'ailleurs pas le seul président de
la vème république à ne pas avoir été
maire j'ai compris qu'on en aurait
beaucoup le général de gaulle ces
derniers temps se peut qu'ils aient eux
mêmes défauts
mais après les bons mots le ton change
le président revient sur les désaccords
du début et il est surtout j'ai
modestement tâcher de faire ce que
j'avais dit la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation a été compensée
conformément aux engagements à l'euro
près il n'y a pas de loi y était ou
alors ce sont des mots si on ne dit pas
ce qu'on va faire et qu'on ne sait pas
que c'est ce qu'on a dit un recadrage en
bonne et due forme est toujours bien
vécue par les maires ça plutôt commencer
manière grande yal
dont je les trouvais assez rude
vis-à-vis des mères que nous sommes un
peu donneur de leçons voire même plus
beaucoup chacun reste sur ses positions
nous on pense que
on était
des poussées un peu de nos prérogatives
le président pense qu'il vous en lui
tous les maires se plaignent et sur le
terrain tous les jours quand on me l a
jeune a compté nous prend à l'envers et
on se rend compte que finalement
il a le dernier mot et que
l'opération séduction n'a pas pris
jusqu'au bout la relation d' emmanuel
macron aux élus locaux restera
compliquée
qui a donc conclu
patrick roger il a réussi l'exercice le
chan de l'intérieur
moi j'ai trouvé oui
pour résumer ça son discours s'est
assaini promesses ni un ni annonce ni
confession ni concession
mais il a
hélas bon j'ai l'impression qu'il a été
un peu agacé un peu piqué au vif par les
discours qui avait précédé un tout petit
pas parsemé andré les envahir
d'andré laignel qui était présenté comme
une résolution
qui était plus un réquisitoire
est bon et il n'a rien lâché sur le fond
en revanche sur la forme il a été assez
caustique assez pugnace et le disco
finalement est pas si mal passé que ça
vaut
volet des réactions que vous avez
recueillis sont
d'abord à la à la fin
il ya eu pendant son discours un sifflet
un sifflet assez isolé en revanche les
applaudissements assez nourri à la fin
donc oui je pense que l'exercice était
réussi ce serait aussi pour vos si oui
sur la forme c'est s était réussie c'est
clair c'est à un discours de campagne de
défense de son bilan après du point de
vue des moeurs
c'était assez partagés on a fait un
micro trottoir à la gazette des communes
et il ya une partie des maires qui lui
reconnaissent à sa conception de la
déconcentration et d'avoir remis du
pouvoir au préfet une proximité avec le
couple maire préfet et et des moyens sur
le terrain et puis d'autres qui
critiquent son refus la décentralisation
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
et un certain nombre de tensions qui ont
émaillé le quinquennat et qui restent
difficilement digérable pour un certain
nombre d'élus mais c'est vraiment
partagé et puis ça va dépendre aussi du
type d'élu et de sa situation parce que
les les communes sont très différentes
et il ya des élus qui vont être beaucoup
plus politique et des mères beaucoup
plus politique que d'autres dans la
réaction mais c'est justement on va voir
ce qu'en pensent les maires ruraux de ce
discours on est avec michel fournier
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce matin michel fournier vous êtes le
maire de voivres c'est dans les
voyez-vous présidé l'association des
maires ruraux de france qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensez vous de ce discours de
manuel mâcon ya
ce discours
ne m'étonne pas c'est le discours de
quelqu'un qui défend son le pilon qui on
peut parler bidon maintenant et donc ils
présentent les choses qui ont été faites
alors il ya plusieurs plein sous
lesquels je vais revenir là la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
effectivement aucun maire détient
sabmiller a fait ça c'est clair par
rapport à la déconnexion que ça peut
avoir par rapport aux citoyens et
souvent que la compensation de haut au
fil des ans ne se fait plus mais il
l'avait annoncé au départ donc dans ce
gotha il a raison j'ai annoncé que je ne
fais moi je peux vous dire quand même
une chose par rapport à tout ce que
j'entends par rapport aux 6 à l'habitude
de travailler ça fait 30 ans hummer donc
des présidents de la république j'en ai
vu quelques heures et je peux vous dire
une chose quand même c'est que c'est le
premier président qui a eu soin par
rapport à ce que nous représentons c'est
à dire les territoires ruraux qui a eu
soin de nous inviter tout au début de
son mandat et rouquin auparavant de
l'avc de cette façon là que ça soit le
président hollande où le président
sarkozy alors c'est bien gentil de dire
il n'aime pas les territoires etc ça
n'empêche que il a pris la température
des territoires tout au départ de son
mandat il y avait il à faire du gilet
jaune cette affaire 18 les journaux
n'avaient prévenu le premier ministre
edouard philippe que ça allait très mal
se passer parce que vichy leur lit déjà
chez nous dans les territoires ruraux
ont les moyens pas sur paris eh bien on
nous a pas écoutés mais on a su aussi
dire écoutez la république est un peu en
danger souvenons nous il ya deux ans les
manifestations plus personne ne contrôle
et qui que ce soit ce sont la
proposition de l'association du mal ou
en france avec les cahiers de doléances
et propositions qui ont permis le grand
débat et ça il en est reconnaissant donc
nous ne pouvons que dire et bien il y a
eu une approche quand même qui est quand
même celle des territoires même si bien
entendu nous avons beaucoup de
revendications nous aussi à faire pour
être reconnu en tant qu'auteur et vous
allez nous dire lesquels rester avec
nous juste quelques instants à michel
fournier si vous voulez bien on va faire
réagir patrick roger mainguy
la réaction de michel fournier montre
bien le décalage qu'il ya entre
les
le tissu des mers et notamment des
maires ruraux qui souvent ne sont pas
affiliés à tel ou tel parti politique et
les instances dirigeantes de la nfl les
déclarations les prises de position qu'a
pu prendre la mmf tout au long de ce
quinquennat moi je pense qu'il ya un
réel un réel décalage deuxièmement en ce
qui concerne les maires ruraux
vous aurez noté que emmanuel macron a
rendu un hommage appuyé notamment à
vanik berberian qui a joué un rôle
considérable vous avez a joué un rôle
considérable pendant cette crise d'aidé
gilet jaune vanik berberian précédent
ca sion
voilà et puis par et puis par ailleurs
c'est également sous ce quinquennat
est à l'initiative de l'association des
maires ruraux que a été mise en oeuvre
l'agenda rural qui répond à toute une
série de demandes justement de des
maires ruraux
le discours de michel fournier montrent
que la stratégie d' emmanuel macron et
du gouvernement ça a été souvent de
contourner la mf par les autres
associations d'élus sur des politiques
sectorielles la gendarmerie on peut
penser aux contrats de roland cette
transition écologique avec les
intercommunalités
on peut penser avec villes de france à
l' agence nationale des territoires
enfin à chaque fois avec chacune des
associations d'élus un peu plus
sectorielle du bloc local le
gouvernement a négociées en particulier
aussi jacqueline gourault la ministe des
collectivités et à contourner
l'association des maires de france qui
est dans une culture d'opposition depuis
le début du quinquennat et qui va le
rester vu l'élection et s'en défend même
si elle est un contre-pouvoir à
l'association des maires de france elle
sans déformer lundi un discours très
offensif on l'a vu avec la motion et le
discours d'andré laignel qui était très
offensif contre le le président de la
république à la limite de la mauvaise
foi même
sur ce qu'ils aiment venir patrick roger
et romain gaspard vous avez entendu hier
on imagine les demandes évidemment des
maires de france est ce que vous sentez
vraiment décalage entre ce qu'il s'est
dit porte de versailles et vous demande
à vous non mais c'est très simple on
vient d'évoquer la jeune hazel on aurait
pu aussi évoqué la nomination de
secrétariat d'état à la ruralité c'est
la première fois donc les maires ruraux
ont une forme de reconnaissance par
rapport à cela mais il est vrai qu'il ya
une différence essentielle c'est qu'il
ya une association qui est généraliste
cela m s et cette association
malheureusement elle fait je trouve un
peu trop de politique parce que pour
dire il faut qu'il y ait un représentant
de droit tant que représentant de gauche
pour sur les équilibres matin nous c'est
pas notre sujet nous on dit il nous faut
être quelles que soient les sensibilités
politiques uniquement au service de nos
territoires de notre ruralité qui en a
besoin qu'ils étaient trop souvent pour
oublier et donc c'est sans doute là j'ai
justement mais celle fournie puisque
hier
vous parlez de ses clients' doléances
ils ont été évoqués par emmanuel macron
hier en disant que ça s'est toujours pas
toujours bien terminé dans l'histoire de
france d'ailleurs quels sont aujourd'hui
les attentes des maires ruraux qu'est ce
qui n'a pas été satisfait qu'est ce que
vous demandez encore au chef de l'état
vous une chose très simple ne descend
pas malheureusement la structure
généraliste qui s'appelle la haie mais
pourquoi parce que il y a émis ne met
une discrimination forte entre les
territoires ruraux et les territoires
urbains au niveau de la dotation la
dotation forfaitaire et représente elle
c'est très clair ça c'est très simple
c'est à dire qu'un habitant de rue
rallier en ruralité c'est à dire que moi
personnellement je représente un euro
contre un habitant de urbain représente
2 euros 1 pour 2 ça c'est inacceptable
et ça fait 30 ans que ça dure et
personne n'a défendu cette histoire là
et aujourd'hui on est nous encore dans
ce type de revendications une chose
également très important et on y
arrivera c'est la 2 décrit de la notion
d' espaces on ne compte que parmi eux
ont dit combien vous peser combien
d'habitants on nous dit pas combien
d'hectares combien de surface à gérer et
nous les aménités rural que nous
représentons et bien nous voulons les
mettre en avant que nous voulons
qu'elles soient récompensés jallet
récompensé c'est peut-être pas le mot
mais qu'on puisse démontrer que ses amis
ni té elles ont aussi droit à être
reconnu en tant que tel donc la notion
d' espace qui a été promise par le
président macro pour l'instant n'est pas
tenue donc ça nous allons remettre le
couvert et puis également sur tout ce
qui est discrimination au point de vue
dotation ça et c'est des choses qui ne
sont plus acceptables quel que soit le
résultat de l'élection présidentielle
merci beaucoup merci michel fournier
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin pour
porter pour nous dire ce qu'on pensait
les mets ruraux de ce discours du chef
de l'état merci beaucoup et puisque
michel fournier parler de la question
des dotations des finances est évident
l'un des points durs de ce congrès l'une
des principales attentes des maires de
france emmanuel macron a répondu hier
disant qu'il n'avait fait que tenir ses
promesses et ne se privant pas au
passage de tacler andré laignel on
écoute si on voulait faire le bilan il
suffirait d'écouter andré laignel
vous avez avec
l'esprit de mesure
la justesse et au fond le sens du détail
qui vous caractérise parfaitement décrit
tout ce que le gouvernement a fait ces
dernières années et je tiens à vous en
remercier
merci cher andré laignel d'avoir au fond
expliqué que j'ai modestement tâcher de
faire ce que j'avais dit
j'avais dit en effet prenons
l'engagement devant vous je m'en
souviens elle était alors candidat il
n'y aura pas de grande réforme
institutionnelle parce que vous êtes
épuisé cela alors il n'y en a pas eu il
n'y en a pas eu comme je m'y étais
engagé à l'exception des changements
portés par les élus eux mêmes avec un
sens imedi justement de la
co-construction par le terrain comme la
création de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace et je remercie la ministre
bourreau d'ailleurs pour son engagement
sur ce sujet avec tous les élus
alsaciens ici présents qui l'emporté
voilà on l'a compris la chef de l'état
il ya un problème andré laignel parce
qu'on le chef de l'état l'état qui les a
produits
c'est pas un problème andré laignel
c'est que à la mf andré laignel à ses
partisans et on l'a vu c'est une des
raisons qui a réussi à faire élire
lisnard et tient la gauche au sein des
mers et en même temps dans la majorité
présidentielle chez les mères
constructif puis chez une partie des
mères il ya
de grandes critiques contre andré
laignel sur son côté très politique en
fait il fait un discours qui est très
politique et qui n'est pas forcément
représentatif de l'avis de tous les
maires mais on l'a enterré de nombreuses
fois et il est toujours là et réussi il
tient un certain nombre de bugs le poste
il va rester encore on
va revenir sur le nom des finances ce
qui frappe chez andré laignel c'est son
insu merci bilité depuis 70 depuis 1977
qu'il est maire d'issoudun
je me suis je trouve ça un petit peu
dommage que
le parti socialiste qui a eu
un certain nombre et qui revendique
d'avoir une nouvelle vague d'élus aux
dernières élections municipales
et laisse
porter sa voix par
quelqu'un qui n'est même plus un
éléphant mais un dinosaure dans le monde
des élus locaux et ensuite sa force
c'est de profiter de la faiblesse des
des présidents qui lui ont laissé la
place mais il faut reconnaître une chose
françois baroin lui a laissé le champ
libre parce que ils avaient d'autres
d'autres
préoccupations d'autres centres
d'intérêt et et laignel sa force c'est
de savoir occuper la place qu'on lui
laisse on va revenir sur
david lisnard france à voir mais sur le
fond ce jeudi le chef de l'état parce
que c'est vrai que c'était beaucoup un
discours de calinothérapie envers les
mères mais alors pas du tout sur cette
question des finances où là il a dit
mais moi je n'ai fait que faire ce que
je vous avais annoncé quand je suis
venue devant vous pendant ma campagne
présidentielle la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation je l'avais dit sur les
dotations j'ai fait ce que j'avais dit
est-ce qu'il a raison finalement le chef
de l'état il a raison il en a même fait
un peu plus après avec les gilet jaune
et et un certain nombre d'événements et
la crise sanitaire mais le le chef de
l'état et c'est l'une des critiques de
l'association des maires de france c'est
qu'il n'a pas cette culture d'élu local
il n'a pas cette culture de
décentralisation et de deux changements
culturels comme le réclame l'association
des maires de france et là dessus on
peut prendre la liste d'andré laignel et
david lisnard mais fait la liste de
philippe laurent enfin philippe laurent
le même discours sur cette question là
c'est c'est une conception culturelle de
l'état de des consos vers la
déconcentration qui n'est pas celle que
partagent association des maires de
france qui eux réclament davantage de
décentralisation et on est sur un vrai
clivage de conception de l'état et des
pouvoirs publics
et fiscalité
parce qu'il a été plus précis que ça
quand même je crois que tout le monde
est conscient aujourd'hui que une
réforme de la fiscalité locale et des
finances locales est indispensable et le
sujet se posera inévitablement après
l'élection présidentielle et les
élections législatives
mais
là où
la mmf
revendique l'autonomie fiscale et
financière alors les l'autonomie
financière et des déjà reconnu par la
constitution et la loi organique de
l'autonomie fiscale non à dire
aujourd'hui
les l'autonomie fiscale n'est pas
respectée netonomy fiscal ne figure pas
dans la constitution et le chef de
l'état était encore plus précis que ça
il a mis en garde contre l'autonomie
fiscale l'autonomie fiscale c'est aussi
le risque de creuser les inégalités
entre les territoires parce qu'il y aura
des territoires qui
pourront facilement prélevé d'impôts qui
lève qui rompt pas ce qu'ils auront une
une assiette fiscale large et d'autres
territoires et je pense notamment aux
territoires ruraux d'en parler michel
fournier tout à l'heure qui auront
beaucoup plus de difficultés l'autonomie
fiscale c'est ce risque de creusement
des inégalités et il a rappelé également
l'exemple l'exemple allemand beaucoup
plus décentralisée que nous le sommes
mais pour autant ce il n'y a pas de ton
ami fiscale en allemagne
c'est une fiscalité nationale des
fractions enfin il est pratiquement
pardon de de fiscalité nationale qui
sont affectés aux collectivités avec un
vote pluriannuel du bundesrat c'est à
dire la chambre spécialisée
des territoires pour
attribuer ces cette fiscalité ces essais
dotation est sûre ça il a encore une
fois était beaucoup plus précis en
disant oui qu'il y était favorable à une
fiscalité affectés aux territoires
infléchi fléché fléchi vers l'est vers
les territoires avec un principe de
pluri annualité et de et d'équité entre
les ferries et quelque chose patrick
roger qui suivait ses sujets depuis des
années qu'on entend depuis des années
salut fiscalité fléchés vers les
territoires c'est une fille non
spécifique pour les collectivités
pourtant ça va toujours pas le choix oui
mais je crois que le débat se posera
inévitablement après l'élection
présidentielle
on va parler de la décentralisation
scellier c'est que l'un des blocages
c'est aussi pour ça que la mf défend
l'autonomie fiscale c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'il ya eu des disparitions
d'impôts locaux il ya il ya eu une
parole non tenue tous gouvernements
confondus aux maires et aux
collectivités des compensations qui
petit à petit ont été rognés en diminuer
et donc les élus on peut parler aussi
des dotations ont perdu un certain
nombre de deux moyens financiers et donc
ont du mal à faire confiance à l'état et
en particulier à bercy ce qui fait que
face à ça ils sont sur une défense de la
fiscalité locale du pouvoir d'auto qui
n'est pas forcément la bonne réponse
parce que ça va créer comme c'est très
inégalitaire ce que disait patrick roger
sacré des systèmes de péréquation
illisible qu' on n'a pas réformé en plus
depuis des années et à remettre à plat
ça va faire des gagnants et des perdants
et personne ne veut être perdant donc le
système est obligé d'être bien plein et
on va parler de la décentralisation
puisque effectivement c'est dans la
suite logique de ce que vous nous dites
ça fait partie des demandes là aussi des
mers plus de décentralisation écoute
elle je suis pas sûr que tous les maires
bien au contraire qu'une majorité des
mères avec la mise en service
du nouveau président de l'association
des maires de france david lisnard lui
il dénonce une centralisation des
décisions le premier constat que nous
faisons est celui de l'extrême
centralisation des décisions
y compris parfois au détriment de l'état
déconcentré lui même
combien de préfet
je me suis laissé dire parfois même deux
ministres ont découvert les décisions en
même temps que nous
ça fait pas partie pour vous des
demandes de tous les maires pas très
loin de là loin de là je pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui que le débat soit
réellement là et que la demande soit
réellement de plus de décentralisation
là aussi il faut remettre les choses en
place
les la décentralisation comme l'a
rappelé d'ailleurs emmanuel macron ce
n'est pas seulement le transfert de
compétences qui s'est passé notamment on
le voit par exemple l'exemple le plus
frappant de ça c'est la décentralisation
de du rsa mais
du revenu social revenu social
d'activité mais en réalité les
départements puisque c'est eux qui
assurent la charge car en regardant les
recherches ne sont que des opérateurs de
l'état et non et et
et n'ont aucun moyen
d'autant plus que la compensation que de
l'état ne cesse de diminuer d'année en
d'année en année et aujourd'hui
bon nombre des départements notamment
les plus fragiles ont le couteau sous la
gorge bon ils réclament eux mêmes à
présent la re centralisation du du rsa
donc la décentralisation ça peut être ça
ne peut pas être seulement le transfert
de compétences mais si
si on dit donc décentralisation avec le
pouvoir de fixer les règles de fixer les
normes et d'assurer et de lever soi même
de se lever ce même le financement mais
là encore retombe sur le même problème
la même dynamique effectivement
d'inégalités entre de risque de
creusement des inégalités entre les
territoires est ce que c'est ça que
veulent les maires j'en suis pas
persuadé c'est une opposition entre deux
conceptions chez les mères il ya ceux
qui défendent une décentralisation et
des nouveaux pouvoirs je pense au
logement je pense à la transition
écologique et le président a dit qu'il
était favorable à dessus mais je pense
aussi à la santé dans différents bords
différentes thématiques et puis à ceux
qui qui demande plus de présence de
l'état au niveau de leur territoire et
là c'est la déconcentration avec un
préfet encore plus fort qu'il est
aujourd'hui et surtout moins d'appels à
projets moins de 2 bureaucratie c'est là
c'est aussi une des critiques de david
lisnard là dessus c'est c'est moins de
2,2 de paperasse à faire et beaucoup
plus d'effectivité de l'état au niveau
local et de proximité et critique
beaucoup la fermeture des trésoreries la
fermeture d'un certain nombre de pubs de
services publics locaux et et qu'on leur
ait donné des compétences sans les
moyens et donc faire revenir l'état au
niveau des territoires c'est une demande
d'une partie des maires et qui
pourraient s'accorder là dessus sur ce
qu'a dit le président de la république
est ce que ce processus là justement
n'est pas en cours aujourd'hui à ce qu
on a vu à travers la crise sanitaire se
renforcer effectivement ce couple
mer-mer préfet oui parce que la crise
sanitaire a montré la nécessité de
travailler en commun entre l'état les
collectivités notamment des
collectivités de proximité par ailleurs
oui il ya eu au cours des décennies afin
d'aider quinquennat précédent un
affaiblissement de l'état déconcentré
oui des fermetures de fermeture de
trésorerie fermetures de services etc et
aujourd'hui quand même ce qui est
frappant c'est de ne pas intégrer dans
le bilan la création de 2000 maisons
france
france france service qui justement
comment dire inverse le mouvement qui
avait été enclenchée lors des deux
précédents quinquennaux rapidement quand
même il nous reste une minute sur aussi
l'événement de ce congrès c'est le
changement à la tête de la présidence à
17 ans françois morin était président de
l'association c'est david lisnard faits
a pris sa place on a vu d'ailleurs
françois baroin ovationné hier par les
maires de france c'est un changement
dans la continuité ou ça va un peu
modifié la ligne de la mf plus politisés
à mon avis ça va être la continuité
parce qu'on voit que david lisnard
s'inscrit totalement dans les pas de
françois baroin et de jacques pélissard
qui étaient là avant et puis andré
laignel rsa son poste de premier vice
président délégué et donc il va
continuer dans la même ligne donc
maintenant c'est une continuité là la
seule différence c'est qu'à l'intérieur
du du bureau il va y avoir davantage de
mères constructif plus proche de la
majorité qui était sur la liste de
philippe laurent et il va y avoir une
question d'unité entre ces deux listes
qui ne pour l'instant ont du mal à
travailler ensemble au final
oui le nouveau
je sais
je sais pas dans quelle mesure ouais
mais dont je ne sais pas dans quelle
mesure cette campagne quand même va
laisser va laisser des traces
parce que quand même ça c'est un petit
peu ça c'est un petit peu de murcie un
petit peu tendue sur sur la fin donc on
sait pas exactement aux convois ans vont
être
répartis les responsabilités bon le veut
le souhait en tout cas sa chance et j'en
suis sûr de l'ensemble des maires c'est
qu' il y ait une unité préserver de
la mer dans l'urbanisme on a donc tiré
le bilan de ce congrès qui a eu lieu
cette semaine au congrès des maires qui
s'est terminée hier par les discours du
chef de l'état
[Musique]